today we're off to Iceland one of my
favorite countries which has been at the
very leading edge of the coronavirus
testing there's a company they're called
decode genetics which has been looking
at the Icelandic populations genomes for
about 25 years when the virus hit they
very quickly started testing just about
everyone they could not just people who
are sick but but a random sampling of
Iceland ders they've come up with some
of the biggest insights we have on the
virus
let's head to Iceland and talk to the
CEO of genetics do you mind just
introducing yourself my name is Kara
finnstrom and I'm the prompter and she
or decode genetics you had one of the
most ambitious testing programs you've
tested I think it's about 10% of the
population and 5% of the population ten
point five so it sounded like at first
anybody who wanted a test could could
sign up and apply for one and then you
went to this more random process where
you you I think you like literally went
through the phone book and it kind of
picked people started to test them on
January 31st and the healthcare system
tested see for 28 days before finding
the first patients we started to screen
in the population in general on maths
the 13th and the we have already
screened about 10% of the population we
have determined that on average during
this time that we have been screening
about 0.8 percent of the population has
been infected by the virus but that
number has been coming down we have
sequence the virus from every single
person infected and Arthur's generated
are very interesting picture so if you
look worldwide that is a tremendous
collections or mutations in this virus
so in this
some mutations you have a barcode and
having the sequence or the virus from
everyone in fact it gives us an
opportunity to determine the country of
origin of the infection in all of the
infected in Iceland another thing that
you can do with the sequence is that you
can use it to trace the infection in
Iceland you can figure out who was
infected from home so if you are
diagnosed with an infection we can in an
instant find all of the smartphones that
were within one or two meters of your
smartphone over the past five days which
is somewhat scary yes it sounds like
considerably invasion of privacy yeah
when you are looking a beast like this
in the eyes you have to use whatever you
have you know because I slit is
relatively contained because you were so
aggressive with your testing and tracing
and you didn't go under the same
lockdown as some of the other countries
explain to me what what lockdown looked
like a month ago and and what it looks
like now as a result of all the testing
that you've been able to do and all the
traces we really don't have a lockdown
yeah we don't have a curfew we we have
the ban on gathering of more than 20
people we are insisting that we should
keep our social distance to 2 meters we
have our elementary schools are open the
child care centers are open the stores
are open we are taking a very mild
approach to this in in general but we
have been very aggressive when it comes
to the specific approach to those
infected and been very aggressive in
looking for them bar screening widely I
think that the societal price for doing
this approach is much less yep there's a
higher price in screening Rattus trivial
that's absolutely trivial I mean this
remains kind of shocking to me I mean
like how is it possible that we still do
not have widespread antibody testing in
in places outside of somewhere like
Iceland
I honestly what surprises me the most
is that we don't have it in the United
States because what we are doing here in
Iceland is what we learned in America
all right you know you have this
unbelievably resourceful nation you have
you know you have the 25 50 best
universities in the world there does
seem to be will here particularly among
the universities is some of this just
down to the fact that it's it's almost
like a supply thing that the reagents
the so much stuff has been tied up in in
China and the supply chain or do you
really think this is this is more of
like a will I am buying my reagents from
the United States okay yeah it's not a
reagent see yeah it is a complete lack
of coordination these are theories are
seems to be a complete inability to take
advantage of the fact that in an
epidemic like this everyone wants to
contribute you are so young you may not
remember but when Dukakis was running
against Iran abrecan when Ronald Reagan
was running for re-election Dukakis had
said when one interview that officials
from the head down I think that a lot of
your problems begin with your
commander-in-chief your company is so
well known for obviously having these
broad genetic models for working on
disease I mean what else is like stood
out to you about this particular virus
you see I've been involved with research
into a very large number of diseases
over the past 40 42 3 years and usually
when you begin to study a disease the
first thing you have to figure out is
what questions have you have to be
answered but when it comes to this
disease it falls into my lap and all of
the questions are unanswered if you look
at people in general women are less
likely to get infected than men and if
women get infected they do not become a
sick ass man
about two weeks ago there were ten
people on respirators at the National
Hospital of Iceland nine of them were
men just one woman children are less
likely to get infected and are dogs and
if they get infected they are less
likely to come see there is an enormous
diversity in the vulnerability and it's
really interesting to speculate on what
is it that causes this clinic of
diversity there is something in the
nature of the potential host that is
very important and and we are not as one
of the world are trying to figure out
what it is
you